RIGHT. SENATOR LIMÓN IS HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO COMMENCE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING.
WE'RE HOLDING THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IN ROOM 2200 OF THE Þ
STREET BUILDING. I ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS PRESENT THEMSELVES. WE
HAVE JUST ONE BILL THIS MORNING,
WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCEDURE AS WE'VE FOLLOWED ALL
YEAR. WE WILL HAVE, TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PERMITTED,
FOLLOWED BY THOSE WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE ME TWO TESTIMONY, GIVING
US THEIR NAME, THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION. AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION WILL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT AGAIN,
FOLLOWED BY THOSE WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE ME TWO TESTIMONY. IF YOU
WISH TO SUBMIT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IN WRITING, PLEASE
GO TO OUR WEBSITE, JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND THERE YOU
WILL HAVE. YOU WILL FIND THE
INFORMATION AS TO HOW TO SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL MATERIAL IN WRITING.
WITH THAT, WE'LL PROCEED TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. SENATOR LEHMAN,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ON THIS BILL. SB 1266 SEEKS TO
PROHIBIT A MANUFACTURER FROM
SELLING JUVENILE FEEDING,
SUCKING, OR TEETHING PRODUCTS
THAT CONTAIN BISPHENOL A AFTER
ENGAGEMENT WITH HT, S¼ AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. EXCUSE ME?
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CLARIFIES THAT NO PERSON SHALL
MANUFACTURE, SELL OR DISTRIBUTE
ANY JUVENILE FEEDING, SUCKING,
OR TEETHING PRODUCTS THAT
CONTAIN ANY FORM OF BISPHENOL AT
A DETECTABLE LEVEL ABOVE THE
PRACTICAL QUANTITATION LIMIT. AS
DETERMINED BY DTSC. IT
AUTHORIZES DTSC TO ENFORCE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. IT
AUTHORIZES DTSC OR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO IMPOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
OR CIVIL PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THIS BILL. AND I
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS KYLA
ROBINSON FROM BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. KYLA
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS,
BISPHENOL A OR BPA, HAS LONG
BEEN A CHEMICAL OF CONCERN GIVEN
ITS ABILITY TO DISRUPT HORMONES,
AND IT'S LINKED TO BREAST CANCER
AND OTHER HEALTH HARMS. BCP AND
ALLIES WORK TO REMOVE BPA FROM
BABY BOTTLES AND SIPPY CUPS MANY
YEARS AGO. UNFORTUNATELY, BPA
HAS OFTEN BEEN REPLACED WITH
BISPHENOL SUBSTITUTES THAT ARE
EQUALLY AS HARMFUL. SINCE THEN,
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THE ENTIRE
CLASS OF BISPHENOLS HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR HEALTH,
INCLUDING INCREASED RISK OF
ASTHMA AND HYPERACTIVITY IN
CHILDREN, CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE, FERTILITY PROBLEMS,
OBESITY, DIABETES, AND AN
INCREASED CANCER RISK. BANNING
THE FULL CLASS OF BISPHENOLS IN
CHILDREN SUCKING, TEETHING AND
FEEDING PRODUCTS THROUGH SB 1266
WILL BE CRUCIAL IN DRAMATICALLY
CURBING EXPOSURE TO THESE
CHEMICALS DURING AN IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTAL DEVELOPMENTAL
PERIOD. CONTINUING TO EXPOSE
CHILDREN TO THIS CLASS OF
CHEMICALS WILL HAVE SEVERE AND
LONG, LONG LASTING IMPACTS,
INCREASING RISK OF DISEASE,
OFTEN DECADES LATER IN LIFE. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
NOW TURN TO ME TO TESTIMONY. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH, LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 1266, PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING
NO ONE. ALL RIGHT. LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? YES, SENATOR
ASHBY. I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION.
I'M JUST STALLING FOR BEN ALLEN,
WHO SAID HE'S RUNNING HIS WAY
HERE ALL RIGHT. TO HELP SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. ONCE SENATOR ALLEN
ARRIVES, IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO MAKE A MOTION? YES
OKAY. SENATOR ROTH WILL MOVE.
ALL RIGHT. I THINK SENATOR ASHBY
DID IT FIRST, BUT I WAS BLOCKING
YOUR VISION OF HER. OH, OKAY.
AND I, TOO. I JUST WANT TO CHIP
IN. AND BEN ALLEN WAS KIND
ENOUGH TO STALL LAST NIGHT WHILE
THEY'RE BRINGING MY SCRIPT OVER
TO. ALL RIGHT. SO I WANTED TO
SAVE HIM THE EMBARRASSMENT THAT
I HAD LAST NIGHT. ALL RIGHT. SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. I'M BURKE
HERE. BURKE HERE. WILK PRESENT.
WILK PRESENT. ALLEN PRESENT.
ALLEN. PRESENT. ASHBY. HERE.
ASHBY. HERE. CABALLERO DURAZZO.
LAIRD MILO. ROTH. ROTH. HERE.
STERN. WAHAB HERE. WAHAB. HERE.
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR NIHILO IS HERE. ALL
RIGHT, THERE'S GOING TO BE A
MOTION. SENATOR ROTH IS MOVING.
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR ASHBY HAS
MOVED THE BILL. ALL RIGHT, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE, SB 1266.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
UMBERG I UMBERG AYE. WILK. AYE
WILK AYE. ALLEN I ALLEN. AYE
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO
DURAZO. LAIRD. MILO. MILO. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH I. STERN. WAHAB. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE 167 TO 0. ALL RIGHT.
SEVEN ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THAT ON CALL FOR JUST A MOMENT
OR TWO, AND WE'LL LET YOU KNOW.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I KNOW
BEFORE THE WEEK'S OUT AGAIN, I
THINK WE PROBABLY. YOU'RE THE
ONLY PERSON I'VE EVEN SEEN
WEARING. BUT I SHOULD HAVE TOLD
YOU ABOUT IT. SHE GOT SO MANY.
NICE. THIS IS JACKIE Ó REPLICA
FROM FROM WHITE HOUSE. AND SHE
GOT THE MATCHING EARRINGS THAT
WE EVER REALLY WANT TO BE.
GREAT. WE COULD PUT THEM
TOGETHER, BRING THEM UP. YEAH,
YEAH. THEY WERE REALLY
EXPENSIVE. YEAH THEY'RE NOT LIKE
THEY WERE. DID YOU HEAR ME SAY
JACKIE O, WHITE HOUSE? OKAY. I
MEAN, I DON'T KNOW, THE REAL
ONES PROBABLY. LOOK, THE
ESTONIAN OR SOMETHING. YEAH, BUT
THE REPLICAS AREN'T LIKE CHEAP
REPLICAS. THEY WERE UNDER
BURGERS. THEY WERE LIKE NOTHING
BUT I JUST THOUGHT I WAS LIKE, I
DON'T I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE TO
ROLL. OKAY, I'M GONNA HAVE SOME.
I'M GONNA HAVE A LITTLE. I DON'T
LIKE CHILDREN. YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO. IT IS CURRENTLY
912. WE'RE GOING TO WAIT TILL
915. AND AT THAT POINT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE FINAL VOTE. DO
WE WANT TO? ACTUALLY, I SEE THAT
SENATOR CABALLERO IS HERE. SO
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL RIGHT NOW.
AND THEN WE'LL OPEN IT AGAIN AT
915. ALL RIGHT. CABALLERO AYE
AYE. CAFIERO I DURAZZO. LAIRD.
STERN, 8 TO 0 EIGHT ZERO. WE'RE
GOING TO PUT IT BACK ON CALL FOR
TWO MINUTES. I HATE CHILDREN, WE
SHOULD POISON THEM MORE WITH THE
PACIFIERS ON THE BOTTLES. ALL
RIGHT, MADAM SECRETARY, LET'S
OPEN THE ROLL. CALL IT ONE MORE
TIME. LAIRD AYE, LAIRD. AYE
STERN. AND 9 TO 0 NINE ZERO.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT BACK ON.
CALL.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND WE'RE
GOING TO BASICALLY CALL THE CALL
THE BALL ON, SB. 1266. SO, MADAM
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL ONE
FINAL TIME. DURAZZO STERN, YOU
HAVE 9 TO 0 NINE ZERO. THAT BILL
IS OUT. WE ARE ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU. HE WROTE.